- [Instructor] So let's review a situation
that we've seen multiple times
when we are analyzing a monopoly firm.
Let's say that this is the demand curve
and the cost structure for a monopoly firm
where it's the only hotel in town.
So it definitely has a
monopoly on hotel rooms.
So it is a hotel, and all of
its guest rooms are identical.
Now you can see the demand curve.
If the price per night is high,
very few people are going to
demand staying at that hotel,
but if the price per night is low,
a lot of people are going to
demand staying at that hotel.
And we also see the marginal cost
and the average total cost,
where the average total cost
is at the minimum point
where it intersects the
marginal cost curve.
And we've thought about in the past
what the marginal revenue
curve would look like.
Pause this video and see if
you can refresh your memory.
What does the marginal revenue curve
typically look like for
this type of monopoly firm?
Well, if we assume a situation,
let's say room number one,
if they were only putting one room out,
there might be a very high
willingness to pay for that.
Someone out there is willing to pay
$500 per night for that room.
But we know that as soon as
you get to room number two,
room number two, there
might not be someone
who's willing to pay $500 for that room.
Maybe someone's willing
to pay $400 per night
for that room.
And so what is the marginal revenue
when you go from room one to room two?
Well, you might be
tempted to say, it is $400
because they're getting incremental 400.
But what's typical in a lot of markets is,
whatever price you give to one customer,
you have to give to all the customers.
So room number one would
have to go for $400 as well.
So instead of making $500,
you're now making $800.
So the marginal revenue,
the incremental revenue,
is $300, not $400.
And we've seen that in multiple videos,
and that's why we have this phenomenon
where the marginal revenue curve goes down
at a steeper slope than the demand curve,
'cause every incremental unit
when you produce more and more quantity,
not only does it force its price down,
but all of the units in the
markets, the price goes down.
So this is the marginal revenue.
And we have studied this in some detail.
The rational quantity
for this firm to produce.
I'll put that right over there, Q sub M.
This is a monopoly firm.
This would be the rational
price at which to operate.
And we can think about things like,
well, what is going to be the
economic profit for this firm?
Well, it's going to be at that quantity,
the difference between
the marginal revenue
and the average total cost,
I'm gonna do this in a different color,
times the quantity,
and so the economic profit
would be this area right over here.
We've seen that in multiple videos.
What would be the consumer surplus?
Well, the consumer surplus
is all of the benefit
that the consumers are going to get
above and beyond the
price they have to pay.
So we have this quantity.
This is the price that
the consumers are paying,
and they get this quantity.
And this demand curve, you can say,
hey, this first unit, someone
got that much benefit.
Then the next unit, someone
And so this total area right over here
is the consumer surplus.
It has a nice consumer surplus.
But we've also talked about an issue.
It's not allocatively efficient.
If it was allocatively efficient,
we would produce up to the quantity
where marginal cost is equal to demand,
but we don't do that because
the marginal revenue curve
is below the demand curve.
So all of this region right
over here is dead weight loss.
Dead weight loss.
So an interesting question is,
is there anything that
this hotel company could do
to maybe capture some of the surplus
and maybe not have as
much dead weight loss?
Well, let's imagine an extreme scenario,
something that's probably not
possible in the real world,
but in the real world,
people could approach it.
Let's imagine this same hotel,
but it doesn't have to
abide by this notion
that whatever price it
charges to one guest
it has to charge to all the guests.
And this phenomenon that
we're going to talk about
is known as price discrimination.
And it might sound bad.
In general, we don't like the idea
of discriminating against someone.
But price discrimination is a
completely legitimate thing.
Sometimes you might see products
that don't have perfect
price discrimination,
but they'll do something,
like it's essentially
the same soda or the same car,
but they make one look
a little bit fancier
and they're able to charge more to it
for people who have a
higher willingness to pay.
And so perfect price discrimination
in the case of the hotel owner
would be every time
someone calls and says,
hey, how much is going to be for a room,
that that hotel owner
has some magic computer
that can perfectly predict
what that person's willingness to pay is,
and it quotes them that price.
And so in that situation,
when the person for room number
one calls and says how much,
they'll say, okay, I see your
willingness to pay is 500.
I'm going to charge you 500.
And person two calls and says,
oh your willingness to pay,
the magic computer says their
willingness to pay is 350.
Well, I'm gonna charge you 350.
They're further out here
on the demand curve.
If for room number
three, room number three,
someone calls and the computer says,
hey, that person's
willingness to pay is $450,
so quote them that.
And so the hotel owner quotes them $450.
So in that situation, for
every incremental room,
you don't have to lower the
price on everything else.
So in that world, you don't
have a marginal revenue curve
that goes down at a faster
rate than the demand curve.
The demand curve actually is
the marginal revenue curve
in that situation.
The rational quantity
for this firm to produce
would be where the marginal cost curve
intersects the demand curve
because it is the marginal
revenue curve in that situation
with perfect price discrimination.
And so, you have this quantity
that it is going to produce.
Now I have an interesting
set of questions for you.
Pause this video and think about,
where would we put price here?
Is there an equilibrium price?
And how would we think about
the firm's economic profit,
the consumer surplus,
and the dead weight loss
in this scenario?
All right, now let's
work through it together.
Now, you might be tempted to
just go through the motions
that you've done in multiple other videos.
We would say, okay, that looks like
an equilibrium price in the market,
and then that price minus
the average total cost
is the amount that they are able
to make an economic profit per unit,
and then you multiply that
times the number of units.
And then this area gives
that firm's economic profit.
But the flaw in there is that
there is no one market price here.
The firm's able to
charge a different price
for every single unit,
and it's definitely not
the same for every unit.
So this analysis would be incorrect.
What's actually going on
is, for every single unit,
the firm is able to capture the difference
between the average total cost
when we're producing at this quantity,
so our average total
cost is right over here,
and the marginal revenue,
which is the demand curve.
So that's actually
going to be all of this,
is going to be the economic profit,
the economic profit for the firm.
So this is all economic profit.
The firm is doing very well
by doing this price discrimination.
And notice, there is no
dead weight loss anymore.
We are allocatively efficient.
We're producing a quantity
where marginal cost is equal to demand.
Now, if you're a consumer in this market,
you might not be so happy
because the consumer surplus
in this perfect price discrimination,
this is an idealized
version, has disappeared.
Because in every case,
this clairvoyant computer
is able to say, hey,
that willingness to pay,
you're willing to pay 450,
we're gonna charge you 450.
So you're not getting a lot of benefit
above and beyond what
you're willing to pay.
That would be the consumer surplus,
the extra benefit for you.
So you're not able to do that.
Now as I mentioned, in the real world,
this is difficult, but
things like hotel owners
and airlines, they actually try to do
some form of price discrimination.
That's why when you go to
a hotel, it's very unlikely
that you're paying the exact same rate
as a person who's in an
identical room next to you.
Or if you sit in a
plane, it's very unlikely
that you paid the same
price as someone else
because they have fancy
computer algorithms
that are trying to charge everyone
as close to their willingness
to pay as possible.
Now, their curve would not
look exactly like this,
where demand is equal to marginal revenue,
but the better and better a firm gets
at price discrimination,
the more that the marginal revenue curve
will start to get closer and
closer to the demand curve.
It won't slope down twice as
fast as we see in the situation
where you have to charge
the same rate to everyone.